I literally ran back and forth five
times from my office to the bathroom
because I forgot the bathroom key each
time five times
yeah five times because like I would go
I gotta pee Oh wait I gotta write that
email so I forget to pee there's too
many things on my mind finish the email
I'm gonna go to the bathroom I go to the
bathroom I'm like the bathroom key so
you go back into the office and you're
like oh I forgot this other thing and
then you finish that and you're like oh
wait I gotta go pee so then you go and
you're like the [__] bathroom
and you go back and then you grab the
bathroom key and you go to the bathroom
you go I need my phone though because
now I gotta take a [__] so you run back
and then and you put down the key to get
you put down the key you got the phone
go back and you're like [__] it's just
covered in piss